let's see how this works yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I will show you a plan let's
have a look at a couple actually first
will we get a simple example and it
tends to be the smaller of the object
the simpler of a plan I'm going to show
you some more expensive objects in a
second and they've got quite complicated
plans okay so suppose I would buy some
electronics
what about computer ok so here's some um
business computers the reason why I
would the business ones because they
tend to have these plans attached to
them now here's what I want to look at
have a look at this with me ok now
you've got this laptop right let's have
a look at this one here okay now you'll
notice two things number one
I don't want to chat with Dell sorry
you've got price here right online price
or you might see it listed as ah I'll
pay was that stand for recommended
retail price okay so this is how much I
would pay like up here if I had that one
for money that pilot buddy and I could
just give it to all in one hit okay
but probably most of you if you say one
if you want to buy this laptop you don't
have a couple of grand sitting around
right but you still want you need a
laptop you to use it so you can see
what's going on down here you see this
it says as low as and then they give
this amount okay now let's write this
down actually
okay so underneath we've written these
two problems let's do this the Dell
example okay okay so we've got the
recommended retail price of this laptop
is where'd it go sorry $2,100 we'll just
we just call it that for the sake of
simplicity okay $2,100 and then they say
look you're going to pay that all in one
hit all at once or alternatively you can
buy it on terms right so like terms and
conditions it's like a contract right
and the terms are you have to pay
I'm out of money for a period of time
okay so it's or $17 76 per week you
might notice it says there you know I'll
learn more now when you go in there
you'll find all these contracted
contractual details one of the things
you will find is that this $17 76 per
week how long do you think it would take
you to pay off this laptop if you're
paid this amount per week this is like a
reasonable amount right how long do you
reckon you're taking yep bit over year
that's not a bad sort of guess any other
estimates who thinks that's too long too
long who thinks it's too short
anyone anyone think you need longer okay
I'll tell you I'll tell you and even if
you do the calculation divided this
doesn't actually work if you're gonna
learn more it tells you that you need to
do if you're doing this for not one year
not half a year well three years now get
your calculators out it'll really help
okay we'll talk about symbol to this in
a second let's just try to understand
this model first
okay now I've need another color dollars
yep let's have a look okay sir
again yeah Chloe somewhere useful for
you that way
let me good say here the other cities
one hit 200 hundred dollars if you've
got access to two other girls
alternatively we could do this now let's
let's do this okay now seventeen dollars
seventy six right now we want to know
well how many times how many wait to
make a baby doing this four words three
years how many weeks are there in India
there are 52 weeks per year right twice
all right now so I'm gonna take my
seventeen dollar 76 I'm going to
multiply by 52 because it's per week but
then it's not just one year that's for
me to eat I've got to go for another
three whole years I gotta multiply it by
three right so it's this amount
seventeen seventy-six times 52 times
three and you get what do you get make
sure you get it yeah seven seven zero
and 56 cents is what now have a look
what's the difference what's the
difference it's it's it's over six
hundred dollars difference okay now you
can go ahead and you can do a
calculation it's actually 32 percent
extra so you can go and find this it's
all it's all been there okay but kind of
the assumption is just like I said with
the Range Rover right if I'm going to
pay over a long period of time I'm gonna
have to expect it to pay more basically
okay
so buying on terms means I don't have to
pay so much do one hit right this is
tiny right but I'll have to pay more in
the long run sometimes that's worth it
yes like it's I might never get this
like in
three years maybe that's how long it
takes me to save up the to buy the
computer you know maybe the job I needed
a computer for is over already right so
I need it now
so I'm willing to sort by this does that
make sense yeah okay so there's the idea
yeah good question
yes good question sir where it says
learn more right remember how I said
there's all these contractual details
and you learn to do this that the other
so there'll be something called an exit
fee it's exactly right so what will
happen is you'll still have to pay a
certain amount depending on how far you
are into the lawyer and like if the
laptop is in my bad condition like say
I've been pretty rough with that it's a
bit up now they're not gonna take it
back because they can't sell that thing
anymore so I'm just gonna have to pay
the whole lot so it depends it depends
but this is generally sort of an
assumption it's the same idea for like
if you buy a phone right or should I say
a renter phone you like I cut how much
is it it's a few hundred dollars right
and I can't afford that upfront so I
will do this kind of thing how much per
month you pay for mobile phone
10 bucks 20 bucks 30 bucks depends the
more you pay but classy phone you can
yet make sense and if you leave you're
like I don't want to hold on for this
two years right yeah it depends on the
plan if I don't want to play a two-year
contract I'll have to pay eggs a fee to
get out yeah well that's kind of why I
do it okay
there's a simple example I'm gonna leave
this me I'm gonna rub off this pot and
we'll have a look at a more complicated
example which raises a couple more
questions so the header you can make use
underneath Dell example sorry Range
Rover modes classroom I'm going to go to
Toyota
okay so here we go let's have a look at
this let's let's ditch okay here we go
so here I am i toyota talk about a year
and I'm gonna go to the personal finance
section this is what the name that we
saw before
yeah well well so it talks about these
kinds of things right yeah okay all
right now of course they have to look
happy they have to look happy otherwise
no one's gonna buy it from me right okay
find out more this guy looks so happy
right oh what's cherub request code to
one to six right okay to one to six okay
what'd you say okay now you have a look
see this is interesting right down here
it says interest rate now this is just
an estimate is to calculate they've got
for us
okay now I'll give you two warnings
number one see this percentage thing
right that I'm about to change for
instance I could make it you know up all
the way up to 20 right this is just
giving us a bit of suggestions how about
look at this see this see this thirty
two percent extra that we paid on the
laptop that's the interest right that's
the you know how at seventy thousand to
ninety thousand that extra 20 grand
that's what this is talking about okay
so I'm just gonna put it at seven it
might be something else I don't actually
know okay the other thing is when I hit
get estimate right this is also going to
show us a lot of the information some of
them we relevant and some of it won't be
okay cuz it'd be very complicated but
let me show you get after them let's see
what it spits out of us
yeah we go now now let's have a look
here this is interesting
I know if you can don't know if you can
make that out recommended retail price
that's ten dollars under 30 grand okay
now I wonder what you estimate the
payments will have to be all right let's
let's go down shall we I can't now what
are we looking at there's a lot of
information he was trying to pack it
okay I'll look at what's going from here
to here say $1,000 right it's the one up
to a full drive away price all 33 any
questions 34 so you bumped up the price
looks like sort of bit over 10% okay
what does that mean we're gonna have to
repay this about per month for 48 months
how many uses that to 48 months how many
butts in here that's four years that's
four years you can actually see it if
you were on your careful you can see
this boy all right now have a look it's
a whole bunch of different things here
the most important thing that I want you
to notice is that over here on the right
hand side here you can now put it in
deposits we didn't talk about deposits
here okay so what's a deposit no
seriously
in this context once it was a Derek okay
so we tend to think about this as you go
to the bank and you're either making a
deposit or are we draw right so it's
putting money in but here this is in the
context of buying something purchasing
right yeah
good okay so here's one Richard this is
important craze I want you to define it
for me okay what it is is it an
additional sum of money this is very
important sorry it is like a bond it's
very much like a behive it's an initial
side of money it's a significant enough
chunk that if you were to say like put
that down on the table right it's not
the full 30 grand but it's enough to say
hey look I'm serious about buying this
right like I'm giving this money over to
you and I'm never gonna get it back
okay might be two grand five grand
depends on the place okay sir
why suppose at the moment is zero I'm
gonna change them let's see what shall
we make it let's go okay update see what
happens okay what's happened what's
happened oh this is this is changed up
here hasn't it right this amount that we
paid per month is less why is that we
still to pay off the whole song
ah good so I laid down this deposit its
initial sum of money the more I lay down
the less I'll have to pay ongoingly okay
every month for esa's let's change it
again let's say I cut down and say let's
go five five thousand okay so maybe I'll
just come down again right now by the
way and this is an important lesson for
any kind of purchasing the bigger the
thing you're buying like say I heard
like if some mortgage the bigness is
always lay down the biggest deposit you
possibly can every single time okay
because even though you're like oh I
feel bad party with all this money right
the less deposit you pay down the more
this thing will grow right and it will
take over much much bigger that what
manages baby yeah well it is the same
kind of thing except instead of driving
your car it's living in a house right
you get to live in the house
straightaway I for example I have no pay
off my house the bank burns it really
but I'm paying them well life is it's
considerably more than this but that's
the idea
so yeah that's right so this is a I put
in 7% as an example they've provided
this calculator to us just so that we
can see I take it because if I went to
different dealerships different dealers
just might compete with each other and
they might give us you know a different
percentage and so this is just so let us
play really okay so if I actually was
interested in I what about looking good
to get missed in it I would go and talk
to them and they would say okay this is
how much we're willing to charge you we
could ask something's up okay so what do
we got so far from the Dell example we
saw the basic premise is you're paying
small chunks of money over a long period
of time that's basically from Toyota you
can see you can make out a deposit this
will come up quite a lot okay that will
reduce your payments over time okay not
Fuji red as opposed to regular there